all
right
so good afternoon and welcome everyone
in the chamber and at home um to this
first full council meeting for
2024 I have an apology from Peter kit
and also an apology from M clarkk who I
have no doubt is watching us live stream
at the moment and who I'm very pleased
to tell you is getting B and stronger
every
day uh will somebody move that we receed
those apologies thanks Dan second Leslie
all those in favor say I I I against
carried
um we have does anyone have any
Declarations of interest to wish to make
Respec to matters on the agenda
no okay thank you in that case we'll
move to public forum and we have a bob
Simpson with us so please come up
Bob as always we look forward to hearing
from
you so I know you know the system Bob
but I'll just say again for others um
you have 10 minutes um you can either
fill that 10 minutes with hearing
presentation or if you use less time on
that then we'll um we'll have some
questions at the end it thank you thank
you acting mayor Tom counselors Council
staff members of the media members of
our community both here and on live
stream this is my submission to the
inago council's draft long-term
plan this Council has adopted
project 122 5 with December 2005 is a
deadline for the completion of the build
base for the new
Museum mayor Clark promoted this project
and the deadline and he is not here
because of health health issues I wish
noi a good recovery and success in
reducing the stress in his life I'm
certain he's watching you actually Bob
so speak straight to
him I recommend the council slow down
and have a cup of
tea the pyramid was opened in
1990 and there's been much talk and
little action on improving our Museum
and art gallery and now we have a
rush I Keen to have a new Museum and art
gallery soon and over many years I've
spent hundreds of hours working towards
that
objective often I I have advised clients
and others not to am adopt ambitious Tim
tables and tight budgets because they
usually end lead to disappointment and
poor
buildings my submission to this count my
submission asks this Council to improve
the draft long-term plan knowing we have
an aging population which needs good
services and will not be able to afford
ambitious
projects we need to encourage activities
with high productivity levels which will
employ talented young people to work and
live in
Southland next is to employ and respect
permanent planning staff and to develop
institutional knowledge and make
long-term planning
recommendations a group of locals form
vibrant inago to establish an in sorry
to establish a viable inner city in the
mid
1990s I cheered the vibrant physical
environment committee and became a
member of the inago steering committee
which was then the client for the major
upgrade of the inner
city competent town and urban planning
staff are who understand
people are an important component in in
successful cities so employ some good
staff
message now I want to combine the museum
and art gallery in the Inner City
essentially this is a continuation a
continuation of a
situation combining of the two is a
continuation of a situation since the
museum
building um by Queens Park was opened in
1940 later the building name was changed
to the South Museum and art gallery
smag the current long-term plan has 17
million allocated for an art gallery
with no proposed
site by combining these activities both
the build and operational costs could be
reduced guests from M langlands and
distinction hotels could walk to this
complex and mingle with
locals I'd like to create a good the
council to create a good Civic Square in
in Pago's inner city a Civic square is a
place where we can celebrate occasions
enjoy speakers and entertainment offer
condolence es and gather to support
causes or or to protest about
issues wner place was developed in the
1990s and Es Street West as a community
Gathering
area however it was never a good public
venue because the prevailing weather
there and because it was adjacent to
State Highway 6 which limited the size
of crowds and because the Vehicles
traveling on the road created noise and
pollution and I'd like the council to
per to be available to purchase and
amalgamate inner city
land which has the potential to have
community and commercial use there will
be ongoing needs for buildings and
activities the council is the only
long-term
player which can amalgamate land we need
sites for local Authority for a local
authorities building with meeting rooms
which can be shared by different
different organizations and we need to
have convenient
parking my next part is to purchase the
h&j Smith site and maybe some additional
adjacent
sites June 2023 h&j Smith announced
their store would be closed in November
2023 and the property is for
sale this large site could be used for a
variety of
uses the the Civic Square on the
Northern portion of the site could
extend over Calvin and S streets where
there's where there's a good siiz crowd
this is an ideal site for new Museum and
art
gallery my final thing is to develop the
pyramid building in Queens Park for
recreational
uses this could include a calf which
opens onto Queens Park could provide
changing and sharing facilities of
people who want to do some active
Recreation like tennis
running disc golf and it could provide
spaces for artists and musicians in an
observatory up the top and meeting rooms
on the first floor with views to Queens
Park for this proposed recreational
building use the earthquake prone rules
are less
stringent because the building occupant
numbers would be
less I look forward to your
questions so questions for
Bob I'm going to hand out some paper yes
copy thank you thank you chair Bob um
would someone
hand yeah um Bob right from the GetGo
you when you mentioned project 122 you
mentioned uh Museum and art gallery now
I'm just on the web we site for 1225 and
it's purely just a museum I understand
that yeah so I just were you aware of
that yes that it was just a museum yeah
okay now that's cool that's all I wanted
to know but I don't believe that's
appropriate no no that's okay I just
wasn't sure thank you R and I don't
really know when it when the art gallery
got separated out I mean
um when the council had a vacant site on
ES Street West they thought oh well
maybe we used that and shown some
pictures on a new building there and
it'll be the art gallery it wasn't very
um smart and so it's it's stayed in
there and it has a separate
budget as I know the current long-term
plan has that in there is that that
right which one the the current
long-term plan which you're just in the
process of going to upgrade has 17
million allocated for an art gallery yes
Y and I'm suggesting that that budget
get Amalgamated into
the uh Museum budget and possibly save
some money by amalgamating it I mean I
think that
the activities are similar and um the
Staffing is similar and
overlaps and exhibition bases are
necessary for both and so duplicating
those activities doesn't seem smart to
me okay
Bob um Ria you um I just wanted to pick
up on the um area that you identified as
being um uh Staffing levels or
employment levels here at city council
we have suggested that the council
needed to focus on employing people from
uran and town planning and I just wanted
to make a comment really that um from
where I'm sitting as a governance side
not management side that I'm quite
pleased with the performance of our CE
that he's actually actively gone out
there and found gaps within the market
of where we're competing with every
other Council in the country as well so
we are doing better than what we
have what how many people are in the
town planning planning department here
in the city probably I would say to
yeah so look I don't want it to be cut
there's a question R yeah okay so Grant
you've got a question yeah um thanks um
Tom and Bob thanks for your presentation
just a couple of sort of things um not
you know obviously the concern in your
experience around the time pressures can
impact on building um however I'd point
to the fact the storage facility was
open Before Time and before an under
budget so we're on track there um and
the team and I'd agree with r you know
the team and particularly the project
team headed up by Erin you know are um
doing a fantastic job of keeping the
pace up with it um but equally um aware
of the need to step slowly through the
processes and not rush things so you
know I'm comfortable as sort of the
council's lead on that project with
where we're at but always conscious of
the concern you raised so um thanks for
reing that and to to your point about
the council buying commercial property
and I think you've just raised the fact
that the decision in low East wasn't a
great a great decision so I wonder
um you know we' we've done a wonderful
public partnership with um the richs and
family with the CBD and that's being
magnificent you know public private
partnership with the support of locks of
Community Trust and equally central
government but I don't think the council
should get too far down the chain of
sort of becoming a commercial property
Speculator I think their job is to
generate up um you know that positivity
in the city and then with that we'll
follow private people investing in
commercial property and I think that's
the way it works based in all cities
across New Zealand but I'd be interested
to sort of hear if you've got any
further thoughts on that
well private developers want action they
do they have a short time frame they
don't have time to amalgamate sites and
that's one of the reasons we've had the
development of the building that's been
vacated by Farmers recently when that
was sort of essentially outside the city
fringes at the time and then the
development of all sorts of things in
the showgrounds because commercial
people could not get reasonable size
sites in
town and so the only long-term player
which is the point I've made in this
game is the council and I think the
council should amalgamate land I don't
think they should be competing with rate
payers I agree with that and I think
they probably overid the competing with
rate payers in the block you but it's
happened
and
okay I'm going to cut it off there
because we've used her time um I mean
there's just one thing that is a
question but I'm not going to look for a
response for you because I'm sure that
you know you ask me a question without a
response no you can respond but I but I
don't expect you to be able to answer
that's what I'm saying so if you if you
look at what you proposed which is
retain the pyramid um by h&j
Smith um convert that into Public Square
build a new app gallery and Museum and
town and do the work and walk in the
place that we've talked about and I I
just wondered whether you had looked at
what the total cost of that might
be uh of all of those things I don't
know because I'm not a quanti and it
depends at what standard they get done
at and I think that um that
requires
good quantity surveillance really and
competence and it it hasn't really been
possible with the russ that have been
going on I hear the point about um
the storage building being completed on
time and under budget or under under
both but I do know that there was
serious pressure from all sorts of
people and there wasn't really much
competition around because of the
pressures put on the players in that
game um and I'm not sure it was actually
a great s
but um that's what we've got so keep
going but
um okay look can we maybe call out I
minute appreciate you very much
appreciate you bringing this to us Bob
and I've got no doubt we can look
forward to you bringing other stuff to
us to as as time passes so you're always
welcome yes so I'm sort of hoping that
you can include some options in the
long-term plan you're doing now so that
the general public can have a say on
that okay thank you
thanks
so if we can move then to the minutes of
the bluff community board meeting held
on the 18th of December Grant you were
there would you move those yes I can you
okay seconded by bar um all those in
favor say I eyes carried we have the
minutes of the finance and projects
committee meeting held on the 19th of
December again Grant you shared that
would you move those yes I move those
thank you and uh
seconded by councelor soer um all those
in favor say I I um there is a
recommendation which we can take
separately from that which I must admit
the wording is a little bit op
Pi um I don't know whether Patricia's
here Patricia before we um
Council approves that can you just tell
say maybe in a sentence word a little
bit differently because it's quite
complicated to understand just reading
the sentences it's written at the
moment can I just um go back to which
resolution that was sorry it's on page
three of six on number four so Court one
performance update
um begins with number five to approve
the forecast changes outlined in the
schedule of forecast changes as I say
it's a little bit opaquely worded can
you maybe just describe what that was so
that I mean it's ply worded if you're
only looking at that paragraph that's
because with inside the paper there was
actually a list of changes that we made
to the forecast for that quarter so that
was C to pass it up to council to
approve those changes to the forecast so
you've got that visibility of what those
changes were okay okay so Grant you want
to move that one too yes yeah okay
second seconded by re other those in
people say I I against carried
at the meetings of the the minutes of
the meeting of
council held on 18th of December sorry
was 18th minutes 18 December will
somebody move that we receive
those seconded Leslie others in favor
say
I can a question on that certainly um
just with resp on page 29 a board box
and a
point 10 15 on that report three around
the kpis around water is that is there
an increase in standards or is there a
consistency of current
standards do we know is there somebody
here who can respond to
that yeah sorry so on page 10 or 15 of
the report under 3 a the water it talks
about the water um Quality performance
measures around back bacteria Etc and
I'm just wondering just trying to get a
sense on is that a increase in water
quality standards or maintaining the
existing water quality standards
maintaining the existing okay thank
you okay we've already had a move on a
second there um all those in favor say I
I I against
carried
so then we have the meeting of the
minutes of the community well-being
committee held on the 23rd of
January move
those you
move second by
Bary I I take secondly take separately
take the recommendation to council
coming from
M um which is to adopt the draft general
policies Reserve management plan as the
approved plan that was considered the
two well-be committee committees
actually the one in December and again
and the one in January so it was very
well discussed um fairly large document
but anyway will somebody move that we
adopt that thank you leslee second by
can I question yeah can I just say
something on that for yeah um I I asked
a question about Camper vans on our go
Park and I was down there on Saturday
talking to the uh the guy Brent that
looks after it and he's been asking the
question uh whether camper vends will be
off to be parked to the west side of the
camping ground but apparently it's just
if you put any vehicles in there it's
just a
b so is there is there any plans to
drain that that section so that could
be opened up
for Rex you might respond to that no
fans at this
stage team because there's a very big
lack lack of um parking for camp eventss
anywhere in BL at the
moment bar do you still want to second
that y yeah okay so are there any other
questions regarding that any other
discussion others in favor say I
I against carried thank
you that takes us to the adoption of the
2024 2020 to 2025 fees and charges for
consultation who's going to speak to
that Rihanna
Okay C counselors um so this this um
report brings the draft fees and charges
schedule to you um ahead of a long-term
plan consultation and so we're just
bringing it up now in January so that um
we've got this sorted well ahead of
consultation but just for the
community's awareness we will be doing
that during
March um the fees and charges schedule
is required to be updated every year um
and the cover report provides you an
overview of all the changes um um I just
remind you that we're still on the same
um continuous process each year to
refine and improve the way that we are
collecting fees and charges to ensure
that as far as possible we're aligning
that with the revenue and financing
policy you'll recall at the time of the
last annual plan that we still have some
way to go to bring the fees and charges
Revenue up in line to where it should be
in relation to rates Revenue um so it's
important that we're charging the
appropriate fees and charges um to make
sure that the rate payer isn't um
funding an a a level of support for
particular activities that's out of line
with the revenue and finance
policy um so um I'll just draw your
attention to a couple of things in the
report um the building and planning
areas have done quite a bit of work this
time around to really look at all the um
activities that they are doing for
people um approaching them for service
and so they have a number of new fees
that they are proposing and particularly
the territorial Authority notice for
both residential and Commercial
customers um and also um having reviewed
services and the cost of providing
Services which are changing
um in line with market conditions um
it's necessary to pass pass on some
costs which Council has been absorbing
to this point as those have gone up
um and then there are a number of other
proposed changes um in that area
including the cost of sorry the code of
compliance review and sign off um the
second area that I'll just draw your
attention to is um water fees so you'll
recall at the time of the last annual
plan that um Council um made an increase
to the water fees to bring them closer
up into alignment of recovery of costs
but not getting all the way recognizing
that the impact that would have on um
large customers um and now we are
proposing meeting the rest of that cost
now we're all aware through all of the
work that's gone into the three Waters
review just how much costs are going up
in that area and it's important we
recover appropriate costs um and that
also applies to the area of
sewage um finally the report just
outlines the process um that we will go
through for fees and charges
consultation obviously that happens
alongside the long-term plan we will
send out letters to identify parties um
where um there is a potential that they
may be impacted um by increased fees and
charges um which will support that um
there are a number of minor Corrections
that I just need to make to the fees and
charges schedule under the area of
aquatic Services there's just a couple
of typos and a couple of those Services
um ranges on the discounts that are
being being provided so just to note
you'll if you the eagle eyed amongst you
might have spotted that there was um one
that should have had a percentage mark
on it and dozen it's been transcribed as
a dollar and another range that's that's
been incorrectly transcribed so there
will just be fixing any minor errors
like that um over the next um month
other than that happy to take any
questions so I think how we might
approach this um could we have questions
um for ranan of a you know General
nature initially then what I'd like to
go to is to appendix one the schedule
and we'll go Page by Page through that
so if there are particular questions
about particular fees you might raise it
as we reach that point in the schedule
but are there any general questions to
ran yes
um Grant yeah um just with respect to to
the water charge so that the1 80 is that
full cost
recovery correct it is so we're at full
cost thank you
buddy is there is there any more
information we can gather from the
copies Creek leases is it is it been
resolved or is it still
ongoing
so are you asking the question of asking
question are you asking a question of
the license charge got any clarification
on it you mean the license fee yeah
which is what's covered in here these
fees um why don't we deal with that as
we get to that page by if you don't mind
okay you can maybe raise that as we get
to that page in the in the schedule is
there any other general questions for re
yes I'm a little bit slow today but um I
am struggling with housing care the
rental cost for one R bedroom units
increased by 6.6% to reflect the new
units built on St street that does not I
hope mean that all the units are going
up by 6.6 because we built you just
those units will go will be 6.6% deer
because they're brand new or am I
misunderstanding it's just uh um through
your chair sorry just a change to the
range absolutely you're correct Evelyn
it is only those new units but the whole
range just had to be adjusted to reflect
that
change it's a slightly opaque way of
wording if I might say but thank you for
the
answer I did read it actually that way
Evelyn I think if you know if you that's
how I read it was what what R has just
said Trish um I have a question about
the same thing in the past um we've been
told that the um funding from ones you
know kicks in and they don't always have
to pay the increase do we make sure they
know about
things absolutely the team contact all
the residents on a regular basis um and
they certainly do that when they contact
them all on about their yearly rent
y okay so we made didn't is and I know
it's there's a lot of pages but let's
just through I think it is appropriate
we do it let's go Page by Page through
the fees in charges schedule and we'll
go quite quickly but if anybody's got a
question then and then I'll try to just
catch my eye and we'll do
it
so we got page one fees and charges so
it's page 54 on board
books no questions on that alcohol
licensing Animal
Services there two pages page two that
page three of that page four of
that page five page
six takes us to building
control page one of that page
two page
three page
four page
five page
six page seven
page
eight page
nine page
10 by I think the question about ker
Creek I think is under parks and
reserves isn't it so yeah make sure you
call out we get to that point otherwise
we'll miss it it's just one line item in
the whole thing yeah um
compliance H 72 board
books pitch
two
page
three page oh sorry next Environmental
Health page
one page two yes Evelyn um um just a
clarification and as we're getting
through I'm noticing a lot of these
items now finished with very odd amounts
of money have we not considered the the
sensibility of either rounding up or
rounding down on the on the Swedish
rounding principle cuz this is actually
doing my head in um I'm a little bit
um
yeah like all these old numbers it is
actually and I suspect that other people
might find it a little bit annoying as
well I mean if it's something is 79
cents can it not be 80 well it's notti
it's noticeable under 20 23
2024 they are all rounded aren't they
yes when you get to 2425 they are not
rounded I presume I presume the rounding
process start to take place would that
be I think that would be a correct
assumption chair so yeah we'll make sure
that gets done thank you thanks Evelyn
good point you're looking for one cent
pieces to making every penny count even
the nearest 50
Cent that takes us to page 77 of board
books housing care
venues and Event
Services two of that just a small
question there um and it it may be
covered but the um The
Snug new rooms that was developed
doesn't seem to be included there unless
it's been given a different formal
name
um that's a really good question I'll
have to take that one
away probably is but I never heard it
can you say again Leslie the snag The
Snug on the ground on the ground floor
opposite the large room that we use for
various occasions it's a very
attractively redesigned room and I just
I can imagine it being quite popular for
small meetings it's a
toilet okay you're going to have a milk
step
[Laughter]
so that takes us to um page 80 of border
books I think which is um Sil venes and
Event
Services then libraries and
archives page two of
that then
miscellaneous Parks and Recreation page
one
pitch
two page
three page
four page five and this is where your
question comes Barry so do you want to
ask it again yes please um yeah I just
wanted to be bit of a clear clear
verification of what's actually
happening with the kooper creek
population have we resolved anything
with
that bar I wonder if we could I mean
we're looking at his license fees rather
than yeah yeah well they they're going
to change the license leing fees anyway
yeah it's one so I wonder if we could
have comment on license fees laning up
because it just says Market appraisal
yeah so this this report just notes that
we've had the Ombudsman report back and
contacts been made with all of the
Koopas Creek residents in terms of the
fees and charges we're just noting that
we will be going out for consultation on
the market level appraisals that they've
been provided with I think I can't
comment on any BR any wider on any of
those other topics um the GM of leisure
and Rec may wish to provide an
update first Mr chair I was just going
to point out on page 46 of the report
the answer is probably there as far as
it can be given at this time there's an
actual heading saying Cooper create
laces page 46 of page 46 of board books
of board books 46 of board BS 46 of 148
yeah
so I'm a bit confused so P
46 at the moment I've got talks about
pipes to talk
about you must have a different version
of board box then okay it's under
analysis and it's headed Cooper oh I see
sorry as it's below my very as this
question
before okay
so basically Leslie you're pointing out
that on that se ition cers keep leases
um effectively answers Bar's question as
far as the situation with licenses
license fees concerned it answers the
question that the residents will be
alerted the second sentence here I think
that's probably only update we can give
at the moment
yeah well what I will see B since you
have asked a broader question as that it
is the intention to bring a workshop to
council probably next month or so on
that subject that's
fine I just don't want to deal with it
now because it's that's
fine okay so what page was up to 88 88
okay okay so no other questions on that
page so any page any name of board
books
page 90 still in Parks and
Recreation page
91 page
92 page
93 nothing then passenger
transport nothing in that page so
PS second page of
pools public toilets sorry um trash I
just noted I can't see it right at the
moment I noted when I read this that
there was increased cost at the pools is
this what we really
want so um speaking to that the pools
amount has been increased at a lower
level to many of the other phas um for
exactly the reason that you're
suggesting um and um it does note my
report does note that um they do the
manager is saying they are at the top
end yes you're correct
yeah okay TR y thank
you public
toilets Resource
Management page two Resource
Management page
three page
four page
five
roing page two
roing page
three
Sage Solid
Waste
page two of solid
West Southern Museum and art
gallery yes
May so um this is South Museum in art
Gary to
Ina so if we're going to go by what the
decisions we've made would be to in
museum of Southland that's the first
thing however these charges actually
pertain to services is delivered
by
tup
trust most of these and so therefore
this does not
actually sit very well with me I'm I'm
not quite sure how we're going to show
these things in our documents it's not
the charges themselves but it's not to
ino's right to charge for images
produced out of the
collection Mel
yeah thank you through yourself chair we
have got this page incorrectly titled
we've um have noted that it it does it's
part of the management agreement with
the trust and we need to um change and
reflect the title correctly so we will
need be uh it'll be Associated to the
trust it's not it's not directly from
the museum because those charges are
coming from the collection and at the
collection site as part of the
management agreement with the trust and
the council so we've just got the title
wrong in relation to this and we'll get
that corrected okay you happy with that
um yes thank you thank
you so page two of that which is 110 on
board books so again some of this will
be to unaa museums of Southland but it
should also have
departa trust charges as well because
the Staffing is different okay same
situation nichel thank you so we're
going to reverse are we going to reverse
all these um European names and put Mar
names first on everything CU I'm going
to object every
time so where do you see it at the
moment like Evelyn's busy saying I
presume she's saying um that
uh the Mary name should be above no no
no what you're saying is that I didn't
agree to it it's the collection yeah um
which is got
the and there
um that should be reflected in the the
way that this is
written correct well also
um the
um we no longer call it South Museum and
art gallery it is to Uno Museum of
Southland so if we're going to even head
this that's what it should be which has
the duality of the names and
toart T is Southern Regional collect
ction facility so the two names should
sit alongside each other just as the
name of the trust has the two names
within the trust so if we are going to
be consistent with decisions we have
already made at this table then the
documents we produce should also reflect
that um it's just about consistency you
were going to add something um yeah just
s to um we will need page two of this to
have two and we'll have to correct um
and it's actually the English side we'll
have to correct in relation to that page
yes um but yes we will need to bring um
page 1 and two will need to be
reflective of the actual collections um
and and the trust not it's not through
the T or Museum that that should be
reflected because they're not the
charges only the Staffing charges are
reflective of the museum so we'll get
that we will get that correct can I just
so EVN just a Clarity more So you you're
raising the point around the name versus
the or you raising a wider Point around
who receives the
income there will be potential about who
receives the income from the um sales of
images or digitized materials that are
in the collection because actually it
belongs to the collection and I would
imagine that what we will be talking
about when we talk about this in the
future is how the use of the monies goes
to enhance and maintain and care for the
collection so as not to be a further
expense
to the public um it it's part of the
user pce process but the people who look
after the collection are now the
collection trust and therefore monies
generated by the collection will go back
to that side so can I ask you I
understand I believe I understand the
point um
so does that is that then a money go
which has get no impact on the overall
amount of money received or or does how
that decision take place affect how much
money is actually being received by
Council through yourself cheer there's
no change to the way we currently
operate it's um we we've just got our
headings wrong in relation to this
because we do have a management um
agreement with the trust it's we need to
have it um just the title Chang in
relation to this there's no change from
perspective the arrangements so let's
leave it at that then but thanks
everyone for raising that so that takes
us then to page um
111 board books which is water supply
dangerous
page S 111's A Dangerous page isn't it
it could be could be 6 666 is no I know
what he's doing it's Cricket yeah
that's no let's
let's oh so I'm 112 112 I have a query
for 112 single so on the for the water
connection charges looking at the last
year to the next year's um costs
increase or removals so my question is
like I'm noting that there's a
$10 increase on registration
installation of backflow preventers and
annual inspection is that a quantitive
amount or is it of actual cost or is it
just an increase to do an increase
6% so the process that we follow for
adjusting the fees and charges looks at
a range of corporate wide factors like
inflation MH um and then I think you
know what we've already picked up is
that we still need some to do some
rounding in some areas so there will be
some rounding within that managers then
have also reviewed actual cost
information looking at that one I expect
that is an inflation adjustment
right okay okay thank you okay we'll go
down to 113 which is blank and so is 114
and five we've come to the end the like
to comment on the
blankness the upside Down's upside down
if there are no oh sorry gr yeah so just
for the purposes probably for public in
terms of framing how we've arrived at
the pricing decision we've taking a mix
of inflation adjustment or direct cost
or in the case of and I think to use the
answer for Trisha's question where we
see that um just increasing it by
inflation is going to be over costing it
not sure that's the right terminology I
this morning Paul we've taken a more
pragmatic approach around where the
market can absorb an additional increase
in cost so we've to taken the point I'm
trying to make is we've taken a sort of
pragmatic approach to how we' pric we
just haven't gone out and said we're
going to put everything up by
inflation adjustment we've taken a
service approach an inflation approach
or a cost approach is that fair yeah so
essentially we follow the revenue and
finance policy which has a table within
it which says how each activity should
be funded so each activity is different
so for example some activities like um
planning and resource consent the
regulatory area are very heavily
weighted towards user fees others are
almost entirely rates funded like
funding the Democratic process for
example pools is one where there is a
market element within the revenue and
finance policy so you're absolutely
correct it's a balance of different
approaches and when we communicate out
to the public we always have a
frequently asked questions section that
does explain um the approach taken um
the revenue and finance policy is
available um and then we communicate in
a similar way to the way we have in the
cover report but a little less formal
language
what changes have been made and why yeah
R I had a question um that may probably
goes to Grants too um on page one of
your report you you say that these
charges represent about 25 well about a
quarter of the total revenue received by
Council and then in page eight um it
says a consequence all those changes um
it will be 22% of all revenue for 202
for 2025 which implies it's actually
reduced as a proportion iag just reading
too much in a quarter versus 22 so I
mean I guess what I'm really asking is
how how does fees and charges as a
percentage of the total revenue this
year compared what we planning to do
next year so um the figures within this
document certainly that first one is a
higher level estimate so don't read that
3% as a drop back um to give you the
exact um amount will actually require
the final full budg before in June when
all those adjustments um but um the
finance team have put an estimate in the
paper and I'm sorry I've just navigated
Away by accident from the actual paper
so let me just go back to it they have
put the financial implications section
of the paper and estimate on what the
impact will be um let let me just get to
it yeah so they're estimating under the
budget model an increase in $5 million
from fees and charges
Revenue approximately equivalent
7.15% of rates but it's really really
important to take those figures with a
caveat because of course as you change
fees and start charging for things that
Council had absorbed the cost of you
impact on demand so they can only ever
be an estimate um the rates estimate is
much more accurate estimate because the
number of households doesn't tend to
fluctuate very much but the amount
coming in from fees and charges always
fluctuates so it just needs to be taken
with a grain of salt it's provided there
as an
indication I take it then we have not
markedly changed the proportion of
Revenue that's made up of fees and
charges I mean that's kind of what I
take from we haven't we've we've we've
improved the position a little and I
can't give you the exact amount um but
no uh through yourself chair I'd just
like to highlight that as um and it's
one of our most significant assets
obviously coming back on stream as as to
which does has some cost coming through
um does change the mix and balance so
what you're looking at is the overall um
balance between rates vers fees and
charges and town was um slightly um
over the next few years is more more
towards um rates funding for the costess
we're going through the first few years
until such time as fees kick in so
you're seeing a um a portion of fees
verse rates um shift over the first
couple of years um that there'll be a
slight change as of course the revenue
streams start to come on in the year
three and it has a percentage impact in
relation to budgets because of the size
of that asset and the service that they
provide so you're starting to see that
come through in the first 2 to 3 years
you'll see quite a significant swing
around in that Fe first
rights Patricia did you have an
additional
point the other comment I was going to
add is it's actually the difference
between their proposed rates increases
and inflation a lot of our fees and
charges have gone up by inflation rather
than the rates increase so we're
proposing a rates increase of just over
9% versus inflation for that first year
which I can never remember the first
Year's one which is about three about
four or 3 point something so um that
difference will actually go towards
there's a bigger increase in rates then
there will be ining charges yeah yeah
that was how I read it the first time
thank you R you had a question no no you
actually got clarification for me thank
you thanks Alan I was just going to say
yeah I'm with the increased uh fees and
charges is there any thought to like
with increased cost that there might be
improved services in some areas is that
a something that could
be when you go for consultation that
could be sort of made public like
improved services like you're talking
about a drop off in potential services
with potential increased costs I mean if
you improved if there was a service
improvements well then you might uh you
might not have the drop off and fact it
might go the other way is that is it a
part of this discussion or so absolutely
the level of service is a part of the
whole ltp discussion both as of the core
consultation document in terms of rates
and in terms of fees and charges I think
just to clarify what I was saying before
about demand um where Council has
absorbed the cost and basically it's
been funded via rates um the user hasn't
paid at all and so often when there is
no charge at point of use there's high
demand but once there is a charge at
point of use for example in those new
building consent costs um people tend to
reduce the demand for something that is
that initial information stage of the
process does that better clarify what I
was pointing answers the question but it
doesn't S really no answer my question
really no you're giving me the reason
why but there's no nothing with regard
to improved Services I think car the um
I mean how I would take this is we we
we've been asked to approve these to go
consultation to approve them or as to
approve them so they then go for
consultation and and I think when the
ltp goes for consultation as well as
asking there's three specific questions
we're asking but there's also a general
question so let let's suppose people
felt that um they don't like the Lao for
example right then there's the
opportunity to make that comment in the
general comment section you know we
don't ask every we don't ask about every
single charge if you know what I mean
but there's opportunities to but if
there's some that we are getting better
at or we're going to do better or what
we think we're going to do better would
that that would be surely something that
would put in there which might medicate
any sort of drop off and
perhaps comment because of yeah
absolutely I'm with you now counselor so
um I think we're talking about two
connected but slightly different things
so level of service in terms of the
long-term plan has a specific meaning in
terms of we are going to raise what's
provided to the community a significant
amount I think you're also just
referring to General good customer
service and provid ing a really good
experience for people and obviously
that's always a focus but I think it's
important to be aware that as we've
talked about all the way through the
preparation of the long-term plan just
to stay still just to
maintain interest rates inflation costs
are raising the cost of doing of
standing still essentially and that is
reflected in many of these fees and
charges changes see what I sort of
thinking of is like just say with build
consense for example you know like one
of the intentions was we've talked about
it I know that um we're going to sort of
have a a situation whereby if somebody
comes in from a building and they've
never really done it before there'll be
sort of a helping hand all the way
through this will be part of the service
which you know is funded by The
increased cost you know that's the sort
of thing I'm
think that that's something that's
always softly being there but also was
us competing against the
market it's a bit of a mix yes we always
aim to provide great service from point
can it depends on the scale of the
project yeah I think I mean that's not
quite the point you're making Alan but I
I do think one of the things that as we
do go for consultation in
ltp that and I think the documents
probably do this already that we don't
give the impression that we're only
asking about the three things that
we're overly asking about because we got
the much broader question where we're
asking people for you know comments how
can we improve things or you know who do
you like or don't like about the plan in
in a general way and I think emphasizing
that is important because we want to get
that feedback and you know that's our
Point Al if somebody comes up with that
then okay you know you're getting that
feedback um I'm not sure how else you
would do it but really important that we
actually make sure that people
understand they were asking generally
not just about those three things but
generally what do you think of the
longterm plan who would you like to see
us focus on what would you like to see
us doing differently or are the same
um okay we'll move on so we anyway we
are asked to receive the report adoption
of 2425 fees and charges for
consultation and we're asking to adopt
those fees and charges that fees and
charges schedule for consultation will
somebody move that thanks Trish will
somebody second thanks Barry is there
any
more chair I think Patricia may wish to
add out f resolution um given the number
of little errors that were found I'm
wondering whether we need to have a
resolution that gives me the um
delegation to make changes as is needed
prior to publication so there's the
couple of things that have been
discussed this afternoon so whether we
put a oneliner in there or adopts it
subject to changes approved by the GM
finance and insurance could you perhaps
Patricia I mean I think you know we'll
put that in there and there could you
perhaps make sure that next Council any
changes that you have made are actually
explicitly brought back so that Council
can see what you've done we can do that
good if it's just hidden if it's just
any documents so we'll never
know okay thank you so with addition of
that
third just getting it typed up are
people comfortable with that proposition
any want to comment on
it
okay so will somebody have we already
moved in
second comforable you those moved in
second are you comfortable with the I
wonder whether we should what is
discussed at the end of that well there
might be stuff that's picked up that
wasn't discussed so
oh there's always the risk that as we go
through and do the quadruple proof check
we find some more things I'm comfortable
with maybe we could add a phrase I'd
like to add a phrase under any such are
um brought to council's attention that
the following meaning could I just like
to know what they were otherwise we'll
never know
really so Trish I think you were the
original move are you happy to
um your move second's happy is there any
more discussion all those in favor say I
I I Against
carried thank
you so that takes us to tab n the
proposed Regional climate change
strategy for muku Southlands endorsement
for
consultation and you're up again
Rihanna thank you chair so um councilors
I've kept this report very brief um on
the the basis that you have received
in-depth and really detailed information
on climate change um through a number of
workshops but also through the council
papers to the August and October Council
meetings which provided a lot of
in-depth information for your
consideration around the issues of
climate change how they will or are
forecast at this point based on the
information that we have affect both
Council and um the District Community um
you'll recall that we have been working
with environment South in TMA and the
other territorial local authorities to
produce this
document um the intention is that
following endorsement for consultation
by all of the parties that environment
South and will coordinate the
consultation for the region our
consultation document will refer people
to that consultation and enable them to
submit on it we also will have within it
the options that you've confirmed at the
um I think the November council meeting
around the climate change options um for
the mitigation for council's own
activities
um so on that basis this is the final
draft of the document that um
environment heal and officers have
prepared with the input of everybody and
it has been um extensively
workshopped um and I would guess I will
will pass back to you chair as the lead
governance rep for our Council if
there's any other comments I'll make a
couple of comments and then I'll ask
Leslie if she wants to add anything um
so Leslie and I have been working in
this committee for a year I guess um a
very early decision that we made was
that rather than produce a whole single
document that would be both strategy and
the action list that we would do in two
stages and I guess partly I argued that
because that's exactly how swords was
done there was a strategy document
published first just to make sure
everybody were comfortable with that
before we went on to develop an action
plan so this is get the same approach so
what we're looking at today is the
strategy document that is already work
being done um to develop an action plan
um that I would think would be published
probably within the course of this year
wouldn't it ran would you agree it would
be I don't think the date has been set
yet but I would think that would be
reasonable so it's likly be I think it's
slly be within the course of this year
um we one of the things that we also
considered was whether it was
appropriate for each territorial
Authority and environment Southland to
um go out for
consultation um on this document uh
separately and anyway after a lot of
debate and we'll go through the what
that sounded like but after a lot of
debate we agreed that the best thing the
more most elegant thing would be for
environment Southland to go out and for
our um consultation document to
reference it and to um refer people to
the environment Southland um page so
that they could so if they wanted to
comment on it they could comment through
that and that way they can collect
environment South can collect all the
comments rather than us doing in a doing
it in a relatively bitsy way um so Les
is there anything you want to add to
that U thank you Tom Pro probably just
to say um I'm really pleased for at this
point after a fairly intensive year of
working on this I think it's been a true
example of how the region can work
together productively and I think that
decision that environment South would
lead the
consultation um and the rest of us would
advertise and point people towards that
consultation is a very good thing
because quite quite seriously if we are
going to have a serious approach to a
climate change strategy then we need it
to be a regional approach we're all
around the table we we've all agreed on
that we've We've Ended with I think a a
very robust strategy to send out from
which I agree with you the the framework
for
action should drop um I'm not going to
say easily but should drop with um and I
think all of us in agreement and moving
in the same direction so I'm I'm really
pleased that we're at the point where
we're bringing this back sorry for
nearly interrupting you there Les what I
was going to add when you said about you
know the action plan I mean this will be
an action plan that's probably
intergenerational I'm not talking about
a one year or a threee action plan this
is an action plan that might stretch 30
or 40 years um so as a large piece of
work obviously main focus will been what
we do now you know what we do the next
few years but it's going to have to have
that kind of scope yes and I think it's
another feature of the fact that we all
work together as a region is that we all
recognized that but that we weren't
planning for something that is just the
three-year term of the current councils
but that is a very long-term document
that we intend to have a great deal of
heft to it um so yeah I'm I'm just
pleased it's at this stage and I would
certainly
so time like to move the
recommendations thank you other
questions before
yes um just to re and um is this still
on a desktop somewhere like desktop
publishing rather than I only ask this
question because if it's been printed
you've got a quite severe spelling error
CU rod car name is spelled incorrectly
he's acquired 2 DS environment sou will
definitely def itely not have sent this
to print yet so I will let them
know I'm the person who seees so so
sorry any other questions yes Grant yeah
I don't think it's a question it's more
a couple of comments
um one um on page 128 of board box why
why is it only just forestry that's used
the
sequestration and within the
agricultural calculation has the net um
emission been calculated or is it just
the gross emission because if you think
about what happens on a farm around
think of a dairy Cal they actually um
decarbonized through milk because they
eat grass which picks up carbon and then
they put it in the milk and so and it's
well known particularly in agricultural
sectors some of the science behind this
is very polarized towards a particular
view which links closely to the chairman
of this particular um committee and I
question and that particularly H why
just use forestry is one question the
second one is as a reflection is that it
seems to be very water focused or see SE
what rise and um significant rainfall
events which leads to flooding but what
are the other implications of climate
change you know if you think about sign
you know um you know heat for example
and what's the impact on our roads and
and it so it seems to be very focused on
a particular event
which is water related be sea rise or
rain and flooding and not reflected on
some wider implications of climate
change within um not just in New Zealand
equally um across you know everywhere um
and so I just rais those two points one
is I'm not convinced that the science
behind how it's arrived at their
missions and I've just done a bit of
mess you know so if if this is to be
leave where um seven times worse at a
carbon footprint than China per
person now that's pretty hard to believe
when you think about almost all of our
energy is generated electrical gen is
generated through hydrogen and that's a
big input into our economy so you know
you've got to start to question some of
the sort of summations through this
report and it and it just worries me we
get down a drain pipe and we head down a
particular regulatory environment when
we haven't we're not continuing to s
check and as any well good scientist
will tell you you know a theory is only
good if it can be
disproved yeah and I think a lot of the
science behind this can be disproved
quite
easily and I'm not a climate skeptic
look no question the climate is changing
I'm just concerned about there's a form
a thing viewed and particularly around
Agriculture and the science just clearly
doesn't
reflect in Net G because if you talk on
the net impact of agriculture in terms
of carbon
you would have a much lower number
because if you think what happens on a
farm to gross Street Station yet there's
no credit given to that within this
report for that I think though Grant
what I'm going to say is that the
methodology by
which emissions are calculated and
reported as a international standard
which you know we have to comply with in
the way that we report and and there's a
huge amount of debate around the sort of
things that you're talking about but in
terms of you know how we are as a
country and how we held as a region
accountable for our emissions it's going
to be the calculation is going to be
done in accordance with the
international rules and that that's how
you end up so you end up with a I think
our total emissions for Southland is I
think 10% of the countries if I remember
correctly re and it's the numbers
included in here I think it's about 10%
of the country's emissions and we have
2% of the population yeah but the reason
for that is because we've got a huge
number
right so I mean it's a simple enough
explanation it doesn't change the
reality though but if you use the mess
and you don't follow the argument that
presented then we look like we're really
bad but if you take out the The netting
of the carbon through milk is an example
because a cats grass turns it into meat
and milk yes some other stuff as well
which will wear a willow but it does
turn it into meat and milk which is a
carbon sink in effect right no different
to a tree but it's a animal doing it
yeah I don't think we've got any control
of international rules but I know what
you're saying I think what we'll find is
that the work of this group very quickly
becomes more about adaptation than about
mitigation I think we will we will have
to be part of the mitigation work but if
you look at who's accountable for what
in the country I think as far as
adaptation is concerned there is no
doubt that we will be accountable for
let's say defending the city so if you
ask a question if sea levels rise and if
River levels rise and if we've get more
storms and so forth who's accountable
for protecting in Pago and I get to say
that I think the answer is very clearly
us yeah yeah nobody's going to come and
do it for us no it's so I I think the
focus of this work is going to be much
less about mitigation however important
that is and and debatable that is there
going to be less about that than it is
about adaptation because there isn't any
argument I don't think about that no
nobody's going to save us except us sry
you had a question Evelyn didn't you oh
more comment me I think that if we look
at um say the timeline where it talks
about does talk about flooding and flood
events over since 2017 but it also talks
about Regional drought and water
shortages and one of the and Regional
dry spells one of the things we've been
also talking about as council is um what
happens in cases of water shortages
and one of the changes we're all going
to have to make is how we use and and
conserve water because it's not just
always going to be freely available out
of our tap if we carry on the way we're
doing so but I take um councelor der's
point about the importance as we're
looking once this document is adopted by
the councils and goes out for
consultation and we start looking at the
action points is look looking at the
things that you've documented so we have
damages to the bridges with water but we
have damages to roads through heat and
those no doubt will be conversations
that um councils will have to have and
we will have to actually address in our
planning processes going forward so I
thank you for drawing that to my
attention because I hadn't actually
thought about the damage to a road of
heat but it's real um but it's just as
real as the damage to roads um and
Bridges by extreme weather events you
know extreme rain events so it's more
about our preparedness and our budgeting
and our infrastructure um decisions that
we make um and we already are making
those decision and making those
decisions you know pipes been putting in
a larger diameter and those sorts of
things I don't know whether we're making
any change to the way we're thinking
about roing I mean I suppose we'll a
temperature will increase by 2 or 3°
maybe which is take us up to the
temperature of canterburg so we
shouldn't imagine it as you know
tropical Queensland or anything we're
not going up to that
unfortunately R oh sorry sorry yeah R
look mine my comment is around accuracy
of this document as well uh page nine of
the strategy document which is Page
125 on board books it's under the pages
heading which sees key components of the
strategy and
mitigation uh and then the mitigation
paragraph it makes the comments examples
of reducing emissions by sources include
the reduction of waste going to
landfill so that's the bit I want to
comment on and so for Waste to emit a
greenhouse gas it needs to be
organic this paper does not say that it
uses a very
broad statement saying reduction of
waste to
landfill furthermore this strategy in
saying that does not take into account
that southland's
municipal waste goes to a class one
landfill where
99.9% of gas emissions are collected and
destructed in fact the landfill and it's
associated lime works could be
considered carbon neutral as the
collected gases replace coal as the fuel
and the drying kills now this document
is entitled The Proposal proposed
Regional climate change strategy from
mro hiu Southland now a strategy
document must be accurate and grants
touched on a couple of things and a
statement like this is is in my view
flippant and so so which is flippant the
fact that waste the the comment that uh
examples of reducing emissions by
sources include the reduction of waste
going to landf I took that to mean the
transport of waste to landfill and there
for the petrol consumption or diesel
consumption no it
doesn't well but but that would be true
wouldn't it the less waste you take your
landfill the less diesel you consume by
trucks taking it yeah where does it say
that how do you how do you derive that
from waste going to
landfill the transport of it I mean how
do you know how do you know how far away
the landfill is wouldn't make any
difference how far away is if you get
less trucks going landfill you're using
less diesel so ranan is that the is that
the intention of that statement it's got
nothing to do with the emissions of the
actual landfill it is purely the
emissions of the
vehicles well it's a high level example
that in the in My Views referring to the
endtoend process so we know for example
as um um councelor Campbell has raised
that the transport of waste is one of
icc's most significant um carbon
emission items so that certainly is one
Element right so again someone reading
this if you put it out for conso
consultation they're reading this
they've got no idea it says that
seriously because a lot of talk is
around organic composition of waste and
the diversion of that and the release of
G greenhouse gases from that now surely
if you want to make this quite clear you
would say that uh electric vehicles need
to be used for a waste pickup I mean
it's a simple statement I think you're
going down a rabbit hole that would be
the action plan then would me
those Vehicles become electric look I
can't I'm dumbfounded that that that
that statement means the
pickup by the collection of waste
unbelievable no that's fine I'll take
that as an answer but I'm dumb no I'm
I'm not saying that that that's what it
means you just told me what it means I'm
not saying that that's what it means
what I'm saying is that that would be
true that the less trucks you send to
landfill the less diesel you consume a
ner for the less carbon emissions that
are sure and and that's what it says the
effect to reducing emissions by reducing
waste going to
landfill it's purely the
vehicles it doesn't actually say that
but it's true isn't it the less vehicles
that go the less emissions you okay so
it is aicle of vehicle emissions okay
that's
fine well sorry I'm I I don't think I
mean I don't want to I just like some
clarity I just like to if I may point
out that this is Regional document and
our AB lime landfill is not the only
landfill that we have in the region so
like when that that statement is true
for many of
our um um sorry point of order chair
this is not an open debate I was
speaking the chair was speaking to me
fair enough sorry Alex is actually next
in the list but you finished first okay
so I would interpret that as the vehicle
thing as you have stated that's it's
fine yeah okay thank you you finish any
other questions no no no that's good
sorry you've clarified it brilliantly
okay thank you Alex well thank youly I
said my face that you know like say
again another qu yeah um well just yeah
I guess that um it's not the only
landfill or the only dumping or transfer
station that we have in inago so any
transportation from from of landfill or
recyclables or anything from that NN
process um I believe is encapsulated in
that statement so any reduction whether
or not it's being transferred from Bluff
transfer station to AB lime that's part
of the process as well I think it
encapsulates the whole process and I'm
happy with that yeah I've got Leslie
then Grant thanks very much Mr ch um I
just wanted to comment that I think
trying to focus on one Global example
which was given as an illustration
illustration of what is mitigation it's
human actions to reduce emissions um I
think on trying
to nitpick on one Global
example and then trying to jump into
the extra steps which would be in the
action plan that might apply to one of
their own specific
landfills is just a not very helpful
Rabbit Hole to go down
that would the the examples used there
are obviously examples that are general
for wers mitigation and in the other
column there are examples of what does
adaptation mean and there are some
examples given there um the point of
this whole document was not to get into
the detailed action plan items this was
the overarching principles and strategy
document it's the place of the the
framework for Action might go into a
great deal more dep
on Etc but it just it just seems to me
that that's an unnecessary Rabbit Hole
to go down at this point well unless it
points you in the wrong direction so R
is correctly point out if it points in
the wrong direction you wouldn't want to
put it into the action plan but that's
how I took it R I might be wrong but you
know I mean Les and I continue to be
involved in that group and I'll that
back Grant did you have another question
yeah well just is there an opportunity
um
as part of the strategy for looking at
where the investment opportunities may
be um you know so um we have a pretty
good um system out the road with how we
turn the waste into
um um gas uh sorry electricity to um and
then spin that off into the lime drawing
what other opportunities and is there a
fund That Could set us alongside the
strategy that if there's a you know
unicorn that pops out of it we could be
World leading and you know then we turn
this into an equal piece of adaption
plus opportunity and I think that's a
really important piece not just to look
as well we've got to do all these things
and the there could be a lot of cost
associate with where is the opportunity
for us is a region to be World leading
around how we adapt to climate change
and some sort of fund that can pick up
and take ideas forward the conception
working with you know s or um
Universities at tago Canary you know I
think we got to be a little bit sort of
different in our approach to see if we
can push ourselves forward well the
critical thing and you know shouldn't be
me answering the question really Grant
but I guess I've been so involved in
this the last year I mean the
the the critical thing when you talk
about
mitigation is that you do those things
which give you the biggest bang for your
buck yeah because you can go chasing
rainbows and say let's suppose you say
I'm going to change every vehicle to um
electric you can find that the last
vehicle you change saves a tiny amount
of carbon dioxide but because you're an
absolute Fortune so you don't do that
you got to do the things that give you
the best bank for your buck so a
critical part of the action plan I think
is going to be how do we determine what
is the order that we do things in and
you know and that's why we've got the
fund that we've proposed in the longterm
plan um so that when people say well I
want to do this and you know be Mel's
people and you get three general
managers saying well you know we've got
proposals the one that you do the one
that gets the money is the one that that
gives you the biggest saving for the
lowest number of dollars and that's why
we structure it that way what do we call
it again BR um well we're calling it an
internal contestable fund but we haven't
haven't used those words in the
consultation document right so it's a
classic contestable fund like you get
any undd situation where there's an
amount of money that's available you
only want to spend the amount of money
where you get the biggest is bang for
your buck it's not first first come per
served it's um proposals that come
forward that save more tons of carbon at
less cost than other ones do so that's
why we set it up as a contestable fund
rather than just an amount of money in
the budget to could I mean you're
absolutely did right you can you can
waste a huge amount of money to save a
little bit of carbon in these situations
if you don't if you don't get it right
but could you could you have a fund
sitting beside that fund funds for funds
um so that if a really you know
a um Big Ticket ticket item comes along
yeah they get them contestable fund they
make that change but then out of that
comes a commercial opportunity there's a
fund that can sit alongside and it could
be from Community Trust o or private
Enterprise that then picks that idea and
runs across and sells the IP or whatever
and you know we turn it into not only
the benefit of less carbon but actually
the opportunity for economic development
no I think that's that's a challenge for
us I mean I don't think it'd be in the
strategy that would' be but I mean
you're dead rate you'd want to go do
right Rihanna I think it's worth worth
noting that there are National Funds
that do do exactly that whether they run
through EA or also through Callahan
Innovation that supports all kinds of
corporate um Innovation and government
funding going into business and great
South do support a number of South and
businesses to get AC access to that
funding um
nzas nzas access that fun
that funding's under the um under um
thing with the current government like
they've talked about cutting it
completely potent I I'm not up to the
date on what the latest position on
those fund that may be correct for the
Eco ones but the kalahan Innovation fund
a long standing have been going for many
many years and we're set up by I'm not
sure both and Kahan have get money for
that sort of thing anyway I don't think
there's any
of oh so I was going to more or less
make a comment to councilor dery I think
that I don't
see that it's impossible but it's
probably at the next stage of things
because councils have got to commit to
this first and then they've got to
develop the action thing during that
action planning I think would be a
really good place for actually
looking at our community and saying who
is prepared to put some money in there
on a regular basis to look at how we can
make mitigations and changes you know
along the reduce reuse recycle thing
even just what goes to um a landfill how
much of it is necessary but also how we
can save water or how we can lessen the
impact of storm events if people come up
with really good things why can't they
go to a fund if we're really passionate
about it perhaps we should be putting
money we were MERS but I don't think
we're at that stage yet well the plastic
post would be a classic right yeah the
plastic Vin post yeah but you're right
it's more the action plans designed and
I mean the acttion it's easy to get to
this point inw action plan I would
certainly this sets a high level um
Direction so we're ask to receive the
report and
endorse oh sorry Ry just look I I've
really got to State this
because um that information came from
guided at Guided by the emissions
reduction plan I've just gone online and
looked at the emissions reduction plan
which is a national document online and
it refers to
solely about the reduction of organic
waste and in its plan it not does not
mention one thing about Transportation
Vehicles so if you like to track down in
your spear time the uh that plan and go
to waste then it specifies about organic
waste and the diversion of it so rangy
if that is a key point that will make
you decide one way or the other whether
to vote for or against this then
obviously you'll take that any account I
just I don't think it's a big enough
issue frankly to derail the
discussion does it matter no the reason
now I'm even more interested is that you
had your interpretation of it and and I
had mine and I'm just looking at how the
public are going to look at it and and
try and understand what waste to
landfill actually means and I mean I
guess my history with uh waset and and
and infrastructure has you know this is
a passion of mine so I guess that that's
why I'm seeing it in more detail and
then seeing it wanting more accuracy so
I can't with hand on heart endorse this
document
so that's just way obviously that's a up
for you point of order Mr chers can we
perhaps um move to the
vote so um are you moving I'm moving
both of those will somebody second it
thanks Trish
um is there any other
discussion all those in favor say I I
against
against two
against okay do you want to record your
vote and you two right you want to
record your
vote okay thank you but the motion is
carried thank
you so takes us to
what does it take us standing
orders okay so it takes us to um Tab 10
standing orders delegation to Mayor
leave of
absence so Michael you're going to speak
to this yes thank you Mr
chair it was just at one very short
observation this is a delegation that is
enabled under um standing orders uh to
the office of the mayor it's important
just for everyone to remember that the
office of the mayor always exists um
it's fooled either by the elected mayor
or enacting mayor uh so if the mayor is
not able to carry out his functions then
under the Local Government Act the
acting the deputy mayor automatically
becomes the acting
mayor um outside of that um I've tried
to provide some uh guidance for the
mayor when he's uh making these
decisions um and uh we have also got a
twole l abson system in the full l
absence which is when you're not at
Council uh and the second is a reduction
in duties uh so that you've got time um
to deal with an issue but you still
otherwise want to engage in some of
council um and so with that I'm very
happy to answer any questions and
questions thank you Rio it's not quite a
question it's more so a request that
this particular item be moved into
public excluded um given a situation
that happened in December um through an
email that was sent to members I'm quite
I have some grave concerns and due to
privacy and sensitive information I
think that I'd been more comfortable
dealing with us in public
excluded if uh councelor bond is moving
that way I would um second that Mr May
Mr acting meor I also believe that there
are very valid reasons under the local
government why we would discuss this
particular item and public exclud I also
had some things to bring up that I would
be much more comfortable were first
discussed for for reasons of the
interest of persons in public excluded
okay
advice I would simply uh note that this
isn't about any specific um leave of
absence request or application this is
simply the delegation understanding
orders it's it's a very generic um but
that being said if there is a move
second um
then understanding orders Mr chair you
can put that to the vote and it can be
moved into public excluded so we'll put
that to the vote um we're going to move
in a second that we move this item into
public excluded um all those in favor
say I I
against okay so we move into public
excluded thank
you so that takes us to
where
register and again it's you Michael move
the reports received for the seconder
thanks Lely um any
discussion all those in favor say I I
against carried thank you um so add on
that Mr chair if there are any further
Corrections if you could please send
them to me by the end of the week that
would be very helpful
thank you so that brings us to the end
of the public session of council um
we'll summon move we move to public
excluded thank you grant seconded Rio R
um all those in favor say I I against
carried for those of you in live stream
thank you very much for joining us um
and have a good New Year
cheers